welcome back to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast today's
episode starts out with a good news
segment then we've got a very unique
feats of strength segment we typically
talk about feats of strength that have
already occurred but in today's episode
we actually make predictions about a
feat of strength that might occur in the
very near future after that we've got a
huge research roundup segment in which
we talk about several different meta
analyses that have come out within the
last couple years over a variety of
different research topics that's
followed by a pretty extensive Q&A
segment where we answered a long list of
listeners questions the list of topics
included things like how much mercury is
in tuna fish how hypothalamic amenorrhea
can affect hypertrophy whether or not
you can split up your workout throughout
the day rather than doing it in a
singular workout session and whether or
not aspirin might actually blunt
hypertrophy and strength gains finally
to play us out Greg and I answered a
couple questions that were more focused
on professional development the first
question was about how to know when
you're ready to take on clients as a
trainer the second question was about
some practical tips that Greg and I have
for reading and interpreting research as
always we thank you for listening to the
show this is our final episode of the
current season we're about to begin our
summer break but if you'd like to stay
in touch with us during that break you
can go to the website and get on our
email list we send out research roundup
content from time to time you can also
follow us on instagram at official
stronger by science
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast this is your host eric Trexler
and this is actually the final episode
of the current season I wanted to make
sure it was a really special episode I
thought who would be the perfect
temporary co-host to kind of help me out
with this episode I reached out to my
friend Greg knuckles and he's been kind
enough to join me today Greg thank you
for coming yeah thanks for having me oh
so like I said this is the last episode
of the season we're gonna have a little
summer break coming up we will be
dropping some very cool bonus content
here and there during the summer break
but in terms of the regular every other
week schedule that probably won't pick
up again until August or September at
the earliest so let's start out with a
good news segment Greg what do you have
this week yes so this is this is good
news that applies in America at least so
there was a recent Supreme Court
decision ruling that employment
discrimination against lgbtq+ people was
unconstitutional and quite honestly I
think it's I think it's kind of [ __ ]
that that wasn't the law of the land up
to this point but hey better late than
never so yeah I think that is good news
what do you have that is good news for
sure so mine I want to preface this by
saying as some people are gonna
misinterpret this as me supporting the
act of reading books and I want to be
really clear I don't support reading
books when I was a kid I refused to read
almost always got it had a lot of
conflict with my mother about that she
was very unhappy but so that this is not
at all me endorsing the idea of reading
books but I did think it was a nice
story so a bunch of schools and public
libraries are closed across the United
States obviously and some one in
Virginia was like hey I'm sure some kids
out there would like to keep reading but
they no longer have access to all these
books and so what they did is they
started just like dropping books off for
people using drones it's kind of like a
flying library which
it's a little bit scary and dystopian I
guess but it's also good news because
the kids want to keep reading and now
they can so if for some reason you
choose to read books now the kids in
Virginia are able to do that which is
good
okay so feets a strength just for some
context we recorded our most recent
episode like three or four days ago so
no other strong things have happened in
the last like three days but I'm
thinking we should do our first ever
prospective feat of strength so I
fact-checked what we talked about last
episode
Julius Maddox did miss a 790 benchpress
attempt in the gym
it was super embarrassing honestly I'm
kidding I can't imagine how embarrassed
I would feel if I had a closeness on
benchpress at seven ninety yeah yeah no
no he's he's honestly the fact that he
knew his Instagram account shows a real
strength of character ya know but man so
you know how his bench press is he's
either gonna get it or he's not you know
what I mean there's really not a lot of
grinding going on so he got it off the
chest it's not like it flattened him but
but he got to that sticking point and
there was just one arm that couldn't
quite push it over the sticking point
but in any case you were telling me the
other day I guess he has an upcoming
attempt he's gonna he's gonna try 800
and I think you said it was gonna be
televised right yeah I mean I'm not
entirely sure so I looked into this more
I saw I saw a graphic going around that
said like first-ever 800-pound
benchpress attempt and there was like
there was an ESPN logo on it but I
couldn't I mean I didn't do a ton of
searching but identify I didn't quickly
find confirmation that it was going to
be streamed on ESPN and like I don't
have a cable subscription so I couldn't
just like turn on ESPN in the background
for 45 minutes and see if they were
advertising it so I don't know well I
was going to give some information
that's gonna be completely useless I
think there is a live stream of it on
YouTube that's going to start tomorrow
at I believe 11:45 Eastern Time
oh so tomorrow's the day he's trying it
yeah yeah June 20th but
by the time you guys listen to this it
will have been like five days ago
so yeah but this is we're recording it
first so it gives us a chance to put our
neck out on the line and decide is he
gonna get it Greg oh god man I felt
really really good about Thor's 501 kilo
deadlift attempt I just assumed that was
in the bag and he completely murdered it
I'm honestly not sure about there's 800
pound bench attempt like I think that
it's it's almost like a coin flip
proposition like a lot of the a lot of
the low rep sets he has hit leading up
to it
suggests that his max is probably very
very in the vicinity of 800 like maybe
it's 790 maybe as 805 I think if he gets
it it will be a grind by his standards
mm-hmm I I mean I don't want to bet
against the guy I would I would say with
like 90% confidence that he will bench
800 eventually I would say with like 80%
confidence like I don't know what at
Tim's he's planning but I think I mean
I'm very confident that he's stronger
than he was at his last meet where he
benched 770 so I don't know what
attempts he has planned if he took like
seven 87-85 I would feel incredibly good
about that I I'm skeptical of the 800
tomorrow if I'm being completely honest
yeah I was gonna say if you were to ask
me will he get 800 at some point I would
say I'm like 98% sure but will he get
800 tomorrow I would say I'm probably
like 30% sure yeah you know what I mean
I mean but then again I I don't follow
him obsessively enough to know how well
he peaks and that's that's another
important variable right yeah a closed
before so for example when I worked for
Chad Wesley Smith at jts Chad Chad
peeked to a degree that I have never
seen
athlete peak before like he would he
would grind weights you know four or
five weeks out like something would be
really hard or like potentially missed'
and then he'd hit like [ __ ] 15
percent more on the platform the the
amount that Chad got off of a peak was
just absolutely absurd and so I mean
with Julius it very well could be that
like a closeness at 793 weeks out
equates to just destroying 800 on me day
yeah and and if if if he was Chad Wesley
Smith it would be like 850 on me day
yeah but yeah so I don't know how well
II Peaks we we very well could be could
be under estimating that variable I hope
so cuz I mean he seems pretty cool his
strength is really impressive I very
much hope that he gets eight hundred
tomorrow I think that'd be really cool
same but but yeah after seeing the 790
attempt I was like man eight hundred
three weeks later is gonna be tough
we'll see we'll see we will see okay so
moving on we've got something you know
in the past we've had segments where we
talk about stronger by science articles
we also have a research roundup segment
that we do pretty frequently this next
segment of the podcast is going to be
kind of a mixture of both so you have an
update coming for our big stronger by
science meta analysis list it's a huge
list of I mean it's like essentially all
of the relevant meta analyses you'd want
to see right hi I'm somewhat selective
like they're they're a handful that are
are potentially relevant that I'm like
out whatever I just don't care so there
was one that was like looking at the it
was a meta analysis of the relationship
between dynamic strength and isometric
rate of force development variables and
like maybe that's relevant to
researchers but like I don't personally
give a [ __ ] yeah so yeah there there are
some that would be potentially relevant
that are filtered out but it's it's
probably like 95% of the meta-analyses
and systematic review
use that most of you would potentially
care about and it includes both training
stuff and nutrition stuff and so what
we're gonna do with the podcast is go
through some of the highlights from that
that meta analysis update that's coming
but before we do that I do want to
mention we are entering our summer break
here which means we're not going to be
putting up our you know typical research
roundup segments but we will continue
sending out our research roundup emails
we do emails with some very brief
research reviews totally free if you
want to be in on that just go to the
website get on the email list and you'll
find them in your inbox so Greg why
don't you start us off here with some of
the noteworthy meta analyses that you
wish to highlight or showcase here ok so
gonna start with one by Mackenzie
shouters at all title of the
meta-analysis is the effects of exercise
intervention on or exercise
interventions on resting metabolic rate
a systematic review and meta-analysis
and so basically what they what they
were looking at here was in training
studies both with resistance training
and aerobic training in studies that
measured resting metabolic rate pre and
post training does it seem that resting
metabolic rate reliably changes
increases decreases etc and it seems
that for both resistance training and
aerobic training the average increase in
resting metabolic rate after a period of
training is approximately 70 to 100
kilocalories per day so like obviously
most research studies are relatively
short-term so those are changes one
could maybe expect in like 1 to 4 months
obviously if you train if you do
resistance training for 10 years and put
on like 15 kilos a muscle your increase
in resting metabolic rate would be
considerably larger but this is talking
about going from being completely
untrained to starting training for the
most part and so for both endurance and
resistance training it seems like the
increase in resting metabolic
on average is somewhere around 70 to 100
calories per day in terms of the
meta-analytic findings that increase was
statistically significant for resistance
training but not for endurance training
but that's basically because the
resistance training literature is quite
a bit more homogeneous and so the
confidence interval was tighter so the
the mean increase for both aerobic and
endurance training was basically the
same but for endurance training there's
a couple studies where there's a fairly
large increase in resting metabolic rate
there were like two studies where there
was a small decrease but the mean effect
is somewhere in that 7,200 kilocalories
per day range for resistance training
the mean is about the same about 70 to
100 calories per day
but there's that research is much more
homogeneous like more of the studies
find that there's reliably a pretty
small increase so in terms of of
relevance it's hard to say I think I
think like the main point here is that
when people think about you know is
training going to increase my metabolic
rate or not the first the first place
people's brains go is like oh if I build
muscle muscle you know exists it exists
it requires calories and so if I put on
a ton of muscle that may increase my
metabolic rate to some degree but there
there are short-term increases in
metabolic rate when you take up training
that are independent of how much lean
mass you're gaining primarily because
when you're more active there's just
more [ __ ] going on in your body like
more molecules are being built and
broken down protein turnover increases
etc and all of those processes require
some degree of energy and so when you go
from being just a complete couch potato
to doing some sort of training whether
that's aerobic training or strength
training there will be a small but
possibly meaningful increase in resting
metabolic rate yeah and then when you
think about all of the various mounted
metabolic and non metabolic processes
that involve some kind of transfer
mechanism that requires ATP you know
there's just a lot of stuff going on but
like you said extraneous to building a
bunch of muscle there are other aspects
of physiology that can contribute to
that increase in in resting metabolic
rate for sure all right moving on next
the placebo and nocebo effect on sport
performance a systematic review by Hurst
and colleagues this is one that I
reviewed in Mass when it came out so if
you're a mass subscriber you can head on
over to the member site and read a much
more in-depth overview of this
meta-analysis of this systematic review
actually it was a systematic review and
meta-analysis but only systematic review
is in the title but essentially so the
the placebo and nocebo effect relate to
either improvements or decrements and
performance that are independent of what
you're ingesting or what is being done
to you so essentially you're given like
a fake supplement or some some sort of
sham treatment and researchers are
looking to see how your performance
differs when receiving something that
physiologically shouldn't do anything
compared to receiving no treatment
whatsoever and this this study kind of
like split out different types of
placebos and nocebo
but it seems like for the most part the
the magnitude of both the placebo and
nocebo effect is somewhere in the
neighborhood of a Cohen's D value of
like 0.3 0.4 which we generally like
traditionally be categorized as a
relatively small effect but possibly
meaningful and I think that's noteworthy
the reason I think it's noteworthy is
that most supplements that one might
take to improve performance are
generally compared to a placebo
supplement
and most of them are associated with you
know based on like what outcome they're
looking at most of them are so are
associated with a with an effect size in
the vicinity of like 0.2 to 0.4 so
pretty comparable to the placebo effect
itself and so I think that's noteworthy
because that implies that compared to no
supplementation supplements actually
have like a larger effect on performance
then maybe one would assume based on
placebo controlled studies so the the
actual like physiological benefit you're
getting from them is a relatively small
effect but since kind of the placebo
effect is already baked in because
you're taking something versus not
taking something the actual effect
versus no treatment may in fact be a
little bit larger and you know I think
it's I think it's interesting that you
know even things like even things like
you're giving someone something that you
say is amino acids but really it's just
like multi dextran and you're seeing how
that affects like endurance performance
or strength performance or whatever it
still seems to have like a small but
meaningful effect which i think like to
some degree maybe kind of validates some
degree of like bro supplement culture
like people taking say like pre workouts
we're [ __ ] everything is under dosed
but they really feel like they perform
better and you know they probably
actually do perform better but it's not
necessarily because of the pre-workout
it's just because they're taking
something and just the act of taking
something can be beneficial one of the
other kind of interesting things or
actually two of the interesting things
from this from this meta-analysis one of
which kind of feeds into the idea of
like supplement culture and people who
just take everything on the market and
really buy into advertising
so the first thing that's not related to
that is this this review found that
basically the magnitude of the
seva effect that you derive depends on
kind of like how quote/unquote intense a
placebo is and so that this actually
tracks pretty well with the medical
literature so if you know if someone
just gives you a sugar pill and they say
that it's like an in said a pain
reliever that may have some degree of
placebo effect on perception of pain
whereas if they give you a saline
injection and say that it's like an
intravenous pain reliever that's
probably going to have a larger effect
so you know a receiving an injection is
obviously it's a bigger deal than just
like taking a pill and so that's like
that's something that that's relatively
well understood in the medical
literature seems like that also tracks
with with like exercise studies as well
so you know they're not out there in the
lab giving people fake injections but
the studies that have looked at the
placebo effect of like EPO on endurance
performance or steroids on strength
performance those actually get pretty
large placebo effect so in the case of
EPO effect size just north of 0.8 which
is like the traditional cutoff for what
is considered a large effect and for
steroids closer to like an effect size
of 1.4 so to be clear that's like you're
giving people something that you say is
EPO or you say is steroids but is
actually like a completely inert pill
but just because they think they're
getting this thing that they understand
is supposed to improve performance by a
ton it actually does improve performance
by a ton which i think is pretty
interesting the the potential
implication there is that all of you
listening to this maybe are stronger and
do have quite a bit more endurance than
you've realized but you need a huge
positive positive expectancy effect to
be able to access it and it's hard to
know how to access that the the the
other thing which
as I alluded to kind of plays into like
supplement culture and like aggressive
supplement marketing is one of the
things they also looked at was the
difference between the placebo effect
from just like inert supplements versus
preconditioning plus a placebo so and
this isn't exactly the same as
advertising but the way preconditioning
works in these studies is like
essentially you so okay let's say it's
like a resistance training study you
might have two sets of plates and one of
the sets of plates is ten percent
lighter than they should be and you give
someone a sham supplement and you put
the 10% lighter plates on the bar and
you tell them okay like this is 225 and
you're gonna bench press reps to failure
and they do it and they they get a lot
of reps and then you also give them
nothing so you have a control condition
where they don't take anything and they
actually benchpress 225 to failure and
so they associate taking this inert
supplement with you know a pretty
substantial increase in performance
because you were actually having them
lift quite a bit less weight and then in
the third visit you actually load 225 on
the bar you give them the placebo
supplement again which they have now
been pre conditioned to believe
increases their performance by quite a
bit and it does increase their
performance quite a bit relative to no
treatment whatsoever and that effect is
larger than if you just gave them the
placebo in the first place without
preconditioning them and like I said the
connection there to marketing I think is
it's somewhat tenuous so so this may be
a bit of a stretch but I sometimes
wonder if like [ __ ] on aggressive
supplement marketing maybe for some
people does more harm than good because
you know let's say someone looks at the
[ __ ] on a bottle or like the ad copy for
a particular supplement and they believe
it's going to
give them steroid like results I get it
might have some degree of like
preconditioning effect or at minimum it
may be somewhat analogous to these
placebo studies on like EPO or steroids
if someone's taking a supplement that's
actually like a massively under dosed
pre-workout but the the marketing has
led them to believe that it is actually
going to be insanely effective you know
we're talking about effect sizes in the
vicinity of one whereas the effect size
of like placebo effect plus the actual
physiological effect of say like
caffeine on strength performance might
be somewhere in the neighborhood of 0.5
so it very well could be that like like
dishonest supplement advertised can
improve performance more than actually
properly dose stuff that people aren't
as hyped about could so you're saying we
owe a great deal of gratitude to the
shady supplement advertising industry
you know I'm not saying that I'm not
saying I'm not saying that's ethical and
I'm not I'm certainly not recommending
it I just think it's like I think it's
an interesting question to ponder so
yeah it is so you know just in a vacuum
if you could give someone something that
you would know with with perfect
knowledge so like this is this is a
philosophical thought experiment now you
have perfect knowledge that what you're
giving them does nothing but if you hype
it up enough it will have a large
positive effect versus something that
you know will physiologically be
beneficial but you know they won't
believe in as much and not be as hyped
about and will therefore have a smaller
effect than the actual and nert
treatment what do you do treks it's an
interesting question isn't it I mean if
you're only if if the cost to the person
was equal in both circumstances and your
main interest was in getting them the
best gains then logically you'd have to
go with the one that's all hyped up
right yeah it's
fascinating I I don't know I I think
it's an interesting question and so I
want to make something clear here there
I want to be surprised if there's some
physical therapists listening to this
who are about to send me hate mail
because I've seen I've seen a lot of
arguments against this in the physical
therapy space where there's a lot of
treatments that when compared to nothing
seem to be effective but don't seem to
outperform
placebo treatment so for example like
acupuncture doesn't seem to really do
all that much but when you compare
acupuncture to no treatment whatsoever
it seems to improve like range of motion
and pain perception to some degree but
when you compare it to sham acupuncture
which no lie generally in the research
that's literally just like you know
you're doing something on the back side
of the body so someone can't see what's
going on and either you actually insert
acupuncture needles or you just like
poke them with toothpicks yeah it seems
like poking people with toothpicks in
random places has the same effect as
acupuncture does and and so people who
are like high on acupuncture will be
like look well in these studies where we
compared it to no treatment whatsoever
it has an effect and then people will be
like well but when you compare it to a
placebo it doesn't do anything and there
are treatments that do provide benefit
win compared to a placebo therefore
you're not justified to do acupuncture
you should do other treatments that are
actually effective yeah but this is like
a slightly more nuanced version of that
question where I mean like we talked
about supplements on the show a fair
amount but I think we both agree most
supplements even ones that are reliably
effective don't have that large of an
effect right correct yeah and so the
question here is like if in some
instances the placebo effect and
positive expectancy effects you can have
a larger impact on performance than
substances that are actually
physiologically beneficial that's
slightly different than kind of that
question being debated in PT yeah yeah
and with PT we're talking about you know
medical care yes it's substantially more
important than like can you do two more
reps with 225 exactly it's like the
ethics regarding like okay like you're
doing this instead of the standard of
care you better have a damn good reason
for it er yeah anyway so I I don't
really know how I feel about that
question period but I think it's
something interesting to think about
yeah I mean it's just fascinating I mean
like you said we talk about supplements
all the time and I think we usually give
you know on the spectrum of like really
hyping things up versus just kind of
saying listen nothing works don't even
try you know I think we're I think we
tend to take very cautious approaches to
how we discuss supplementation so like
you know
citrulline malate yeah it looks like it
you know works with like a trivial to
small effect size you might get
something out of it it's justifiable but
you know you shouldn't be like more
excited on your way to gym because
you're like now I'm on citrulline malate
so shit's really going down yeah so I
think we try to give a pretty cautious
representation of what to expect from
these things but but it is really
fascinating to think about like if
you're overly cautious are you like no
see Boeing people out of an actual
benefit I want to say no see no see
Boeing but I would say like potentially
reducing the magnitude right yes you
both effect yeah since the placebo
effect is additive with the actual
physiological effect and maybe has a
similar impact as the actual
physiological effect itself maybe where
the monsters here Trek's it's possible
maybe we should just be saying like dude
I tried citrulline malate and I don't
know how I can go back like if I had to
train without citrulline malate I
probably would just stop training
because there's no point yeah you know
this this really raises an interesting
question about tea teleological versus
day ontological ethics and we're just
not going to answer that question no
people can argue about it in the YouTube
comments and we're not going to weigh in
yeah alright let's move on so there were
I think these are my last two there were
two meta-analyses on foam rolling
recently the first is a meta-analysis of
the effects of foam rolling on
performance and recovery oh I'm gonna
assume this is a German name and
pronounce it Viva hava which may be
entirely incorrect anyway so this like I
said was looking at performance and
recovery the second one I'm going to
talk about was looking at range of
motion and in terms of the effects of
foam rolling on performance and recovery
if you film roll before exercise it does
seem like it has a small beneficial
effect on sprint performance but not
jumping performance or strength and the
effects on sprint performance are
relatively small as well so for for
certain types of exercise including foam
rolling in your warm-up routine may have
a beneficial effect doesn't seem like
it's gonna have a negative effect but
for the most part like you know if it
makes you feel good before training do
it but don't expect a notable acute
effect on performance and in terms of
post training foam rolling after
exercise does seem to have a small but
statistically significant effect on
acute post training strength decreases
decreases in sprint speed and muscle
pain perception which i think is fairly
interesting and it's hard to know how
relevant that is in a lot of
circumstances so for example when I'm
talking about acute post training
decreases I'm talking like you know you
you do a workout you foam roll and then
you test strength you know 30 minutes or
an hour post exercise versus you
exercise you don't foam roll any tests
strength 30 minutes or an hour post
exercise so in that context it does seem
like foam rolling is is useful and
beneficial it's hard to know if that
would actually
equate to improve performance over 24 48
72 hours post training I'm somewhat
skeptical that it would but it could be
relevant in certain circumstances so
maybe if you're doing two a day workouts
possibly it could have an effect even
though that's a little bit of a stretch
but if you're say competing in a
strongman show and you you know you do
an event it's really hard foam roll
after and your next event is gonna be in
like 30 minutes it may have some sort of
beneficial effect there or even
potentially and I don't know I don't
know what this would do to like locker
room culture but even potentially like
if if you're dealing with athletes and
you go back to the locker room at
halftime and you know give all your kids
some foam rollers to roll around a
little bit at halftime may have a small
beneficial effect there so you know
overall doesn't seem like foam rolling
has a huge effect on performance either
way but you know seems seems neutral to
slightly positive if if it's something
you want to include in your warmup and
or cool down go for it but don't expect
like a night and day difference because
of it
the second foam rolling meta analysis is
acute effects of foam rolling on range
of motion in healthy adults a systematic
review with multi-level meta analysis my
Wilk and colleagues and so like I said
this was looking at range of motion
which is I think the main reason someone
would foam roll they want to acutely
increase range of motion and as far as
that goes it seems like foam rolling
does have a relatively notable effect on
acute range of motion but notably in
this meta-analysis they also looked at
studies that compared foam rolling to
just static stretching and it doesn't
seem that foam rolling has a larger
acute impact on range of motion than
just static stretching does it may be a
better option in some circumstances
because for for very very short
performance if you static stretch very
aggressively it can decrease strength
and power performance whereas foam
rolling doesn't seem to reliably do that
so you know if your and I don't know why
you would do this but if you are
stretching or foam rolling five minutes
before you are about to do like a max
attempt squat like if if that was an
option foam rolling would be the better
choice than stretching in that context
but the the effects of stretching on
strength and power performance seem to
dissipate pretty quickly and seem to be
completely wiped out by by like
subsequent dynamic warm-up stuff so you
know if if you're stretching and/or foam
rolling at the start of a warm-up
routine and you're gonna do stuff after
before actually doing stuff that's hard
where you're trying to exert maximal
force or power both are probably equally
fine so you know if if you're doing it
for acute increases in range of motion
and you prefer foam rolling de
stretching you can foam roll if you just
prefer to stretch you can stretch if you
like both because they both feel good
this is the camp I'm in you can do both
but again like it does have a notable
effect but if you compare it to
stretching both seem to be equally
effective do what feels right to you in
your heart oh I actually had one more
one more systematic review to talk about
so this one I thought was was
interesting because it relates to
another technology that came on the
market
I think it's been used in in like
research context for various like like
brain issues for quite a bit longer and
maybe in like learning context but the
the performance research just started I
don't know maybe five years ago it's
it's not a very old technology for for
performance stuff and that is
transcranial direct current stimulation
or tDCS and when I first saw advert
Huysmans for consumer products that use
tDCS I was incredibly skeptical I forget
the company name but there was there was
one that was like headphones with like
little things built in that were
supposed to be able to stimulate your
brain and it would supercharge your
performance and help you like learn new
athletic skills quicker and recover
faster and blah blah blah
and I saw that and I was just like this
has to be the biggest load of [ __ ]
I've ever seen like I don't know it just
seemed grossly implausible but now time
has passed and there have been quite a
few studies on the topic and it does
actually seem like transcranial direct
current stimulation does pretty reliably
improve strength performance and
strength endurance performance the the
systematic review was also looking at
endurance performance and it there are
some studies suggesting that tDCS also
improves endurance performance but there
are quite a few null findings in that
area so that that's a little bit less
clear but it does seem like tDCS has a
small but notable effect on strength and
strength endurance now I'm still grossly
skeptical of consumer products one
because I haven't seen many studies like
validating them against research grade
stuff and two because my understanding
of the technology is that the actual
electrodes need to be placed on the head
in pretty precise locations to make sure
you're stimulating the correct regions
of the brain for it to have a beneficial
effect and I just don't have enough
faith in consumers to to think that they
would like reliably always put the
electrodes in the exact right places to
to have that effect I you know I think
people certainly could I don't think
folks in general are completely
incompetent but it seems like the type
of thing that
one would expect or want some sort of
like trained professional to teach to
teach people and give them like some
degree of training to make sure they
were using the device properly and I
doubt that occurs I you buy a consumer
TVCs device and you know immediately
someone from the company flies out to
show you how to use it so I'm skeptical
I'm skeptical of the consumer grade
stuff but in terms of like research
purposes the the technology itself does
actually seem to be pretty promising and
seems to reliably improve strength and
strength endurance good stuff so I'm
gonna go through a few of the medes that
kind of jumped out to me as I was
looking over the update here and some of
them are going to be quite familiar to
our listeners because they are metas
that we have discussed in the past and
you know there's a lot of content on
stronger by science and a lot of mass
content that predates my participation
in both organizations and I know that a
lot of the Trek's heads out there at rex
nation doesn't really consider that to
be part of the canonical texts of
stronger by science and mass but I'm
gonna encourage people for this
particular article welcome it into the
fold because there's some good stuff in
here so the first one I want to
highlight is actually a meta I did it's
my citrulline meta analysis and the Dex
what a [ __ ] flex so this is one that
we mentioned earlier talking about the
effects of citrulline we actually talked
about this last episode discussing
betaine right we talked about how the
citrulline literature starting out there
were quite a few moderate effect sizes
coming out and then a lot of the more
recent research was more on the e you
know no effect too trivial effect sizes
and so in 2019 I published a
meta-analysis on citrulline
supplementation and it did show a
statistically significant positive
effect but it was you know it was an
effect size of about 0.2 and like I said
there is that kind of interesting trend
in the data where the more recent
studies seem to be reporting lower and
lower effect sizes so in that
meta-analysis you'll notice that
kind of I present the findings I mean
hell it's it's a meta right you say
you're gonna do it then you do it and
there's not much you can do about it and
so I say you know here's the pooled
effect size but it's important to be
cautious with this body of literature
because you know we expect the
literature to grow that there's a little
over a dozen studies that fit the
meta-analysis and as more and more come
out I think we're gonna get a more more
precise more refined understanding of
exactly what effect size we can expect
from citrulline malate but the good news
is you know a lot of the studies with
the largest effect sizes tend to be
looking at the stuff that I find most
relatable to my training so using a
fixed load on a barbell doing reps to
fatigue those are the studies that seem
to report some of the more promising
findings in that citrulline literature
so you know we'll see time will tell if
if that effect size continues to shift I
mean like I said the first few studies
come out and we're like maybe this is an
effect size of like point four and then
more stuff comes out and we're like
maybe point two so time will tell but
there's certainly enough there are
enough positive glimmers in that
citrulline literature when it comes to
strength and power outcomes to at least
justify saying okay you know it ain't
creatine but it might be useful and you
know based on what you're saying with
placebo now I'm thinking maybe we should
just say honestly it's not creatine
because it's 30 times better you're
never gonna believe it
being sarcastic I mean it's a small
effect it's kind of right in line with
what you'd expect from some of those
second to your supplements like you know
caffeine for strength purposes maybe
beta alanine for certain outcomes it's
kind of on that tier of supplementation
it's no creatine and the more research
that comes out the more we really we
really see that you know if you were
hoping I know early on with the beta
alanine literature people were like this
might be the next creatine and we it's
it's just not and the same things true
with citrulline malate where we're kind
of coming down to earth a little bit in
terms of what we think that that true
effect size is I have a question about
citrulline and/or nitrate
supplementation sure okay so
I have gone through periods in my life
where my diet wasn't just like god-awful
but I also just didn't eat vegetables so
like I assumed I had virtually no
nitrate in my diet probably because I
also don't eat cured meats so I'm not
even getting like that sort of nitrate
and during that period I learned about
citrulline malate and I thought like oh
well this seems cool this was before
some of those less promising studies
came out everything seemed to be coming
up citrulline malate at the time and so
I took it and like I don't want to sound
like too much of a supplement advertiser
and I'm not trying to I'm not trying to
to play into what we were talking about
before with like trying to placebo
people but I experienced the skin
splitting pumps that they talked about
in unlike supplement bottles and I was
like holy [ __ ] this stuff is crazy
and so like I took it for a while it was
good and then like for whatever reason I
just didn't finish the bottle of it and
then my life started calming down more I
started being less of a piece of [ __ ]
started eating vegetables again and a
generally more more balanced diet and I
likes all the citrulline in kind of like
the back of like the the under sink
cabinet in the bathroom I was like oh I
remember this [ __ ] like let's try it
again and I did and I didn't really
notice much of an effect certainly not
the same sort of effect as I noticed
before so this is this is a completely
off topic and out-of-left-field
discussion but is it plausible that
citrulline and/or nitrate
supplementation the degree to which it
actually affects you could be
proportional to how shitty your diet is
so if if you don't eat vegetables or
consume like nitrate rich whatever you
know it is it possible that the effect
is actually larger and more nodal
versus if you have like a healthy
lifestyle and balanced diet it doesn't
really do much for you well I would say
to an extent yes I mean you probably had
like a clinical deficiency he probably
had a complete inability to generate
nitric oxide it's amazing that you had a
functioning circulatory system no but I
would certainly imagine especially for
those types of effects
I would certainly imagine that the the
subjective experience that the perceived
effects would be much more notable when
there's a much more stark contrast
between you know what you have been
doing and now adding citrulline to the
mix I still think you know because we've
seen a lot of a lot of research showing
citrulline malate and also some nitrate
supplements to still have benefits in
samples that have you know a decent
amount of vegetable intake I I don't
think that you know if you're like you
know what I eat salad once a week so
these won't won't help me whatsoever I
don't think it would be fair to make
that extreme of a jump oh no I wasn't
saying yeah yeah yeah like more like a
proportional thing versus like a binary
thing yeah I would expect intuitively
that if you just absolutely had no
vegetables and overnight you're like
okay I'm doing eight grams of citrulline
malate and I'm also going to have some
beetroot juice you would probably have a
very different training experience
compared to someone who is on a pretty
balanced diet and added them in I don't
think that just your typical balanced
diet alone would completely eliminate
the ergogenic potential of them but but
I think you're right I think it would be
quite a stark contrast if you had a very
low nitrate diet to start with sweet
yeah I feel like I feel like supplement
research just needs to needs to pay more
heed and cater more to all of the
degenerates out there like we I would
say that that my my people are
underrepresented in the literature and
quite frankly I feel discriminated
against
yeah I thought you're gonna go the other
direction and say like why don't these
supplement trials just like bring in a
sample of 40 people keep them in a
metabolic ward standardize their entire
diet for three weeks and then do the
supplementation you know which would be
a great idea I actually would be
interested in in seeing a study like
that like combined nitrate and
citrulline supplementation with with
some sort of like baseline dietary
screen and you just like screen out
people who have normal diets and you
include people who have like very high
nitrate diets like you include those
people and you include people with a
very low nitrate diets to see if that
had an impact I think that would be a
pretty cool study yeah I mean so I've
done some original research on
citrulline and beetroot juice and we did
do an assessment of their kind of
habitual nitrate intake and we tested
for some interactions basically to say
like okay did that seem to affect our
outcomes and we didn't find anything
notable went when probing those
interactions but that's obviously very
different from doing a more formal you
know there are more intensive ways of
kind of screening for that versus just
like okay what's a general vibe of their
typical
nitrate intake right like yeah yeah if
you were to standardize the diet for a
certain amount of time then that would
obviously be a big step up alright so
moving on there were a couple other
metas in this list that we talked about
last episode oh actually first I want to
make clear when I was talking about
never eating vegetables that was when I
was in undergrad and like my entire diet
was just like rice beans and bone-in
skin-on chicken thighs cuz I had no
money vegetables are good I'm not
recommending people don't eat vegetables
I only didn't eat vegetables because I
literally could not afford vegetables
mmm let it be known fair enough it is
documented it's on the record okay so
moving on last episode we talked a
little bit about that med
with vitamin C looking at effects on
recovery and again just to kind of
highlight those results there were some
some modest effects on oxidative stress
and inflammation biomarkers but when it
came down to the stuff we care about
soreness and strength recovery it just
didn't seem to do much and it kind of
added to that pile of research we've
talked about previously where it's like
this high dose vitamin C it's probably
not gonna blunt your hypertrophy as much
as people what would indicate but but
the real reason I'm not a big fan of it
is I just don't see much of an upside
for it for you know if you're a healthy
individual I just don't understand why
you'd be going with this super high
vitamin C supplementation we also talked
a little bit about betaine there was a
meta-analysis that came out looking at B
Jaynes effect on a variety of adiposity
related outcomes so things like BMI body
weight body fat percentage stuff like
that and I actually reviewed this in
mass a few months back but one of the
things to keep in mind there is it was a
meta-analysis but there was like six
total studies and like I said it there
were multiple indices of adiposity so
like the analysis for just body fat it
didn't even contain all of those six you
know maybe just hypothetically out of
those six four of them reported body fat
so for each of the outcomes there's a
different number of studies but they
were all equal to or less than six and
so for the ones that were like most
important looking at body fat percentage
or fat masked to me I'm more interested
in that than like BMI for example what
you find is that they were basically the
results were driven by two studies it
was Khalifa's paper from 2013 and
Khalifa's paper from 2018 that that were
really driving those results so it's
kind of a cautionary tale when you look
at a meta-analysis I think a lot of
times we have a reflexive kind of
response where we think okay well these
are the results of a meta so this is
like set in stone you have to look into
it be like okay is this a you know
cumulative kind of pooled effect size
from an enormous body of literature or
this literally just the results of two
studies yeah and so if it's literally
the results of two studies then you have
to proceed with a lot more caution than
if it's like hey we found 30 studies on
the topic and here's a very nice tight
confidence interval that we calculated
so another thing I wanted to bring up so
last week's episode I talked about a
meta with sodium bicarbonate
supplementation I forgot to highlight a
very important detail with that so it
did find that sodium bicarbonate
significantly increases strength
endurance but not maximal strength
something important to keep in mind
there was an enormous outlier for the
muscular endurance outcomes and so they
did a very nice job on the meta by the
way and they said hey there's an outlier
that's a good step if you're doing it if
you're doing a meta-analysis and you
notice an enormous outlier you should do
something about it unfortunately a lot
don't but what they did is okay huge
outlier let's retest it with that
outlier removed as a sensitivity
analysis and what they found was the
results were still significant without
that big outlier so it didn't change the
conclusion but it does mean that when
you see those effect sizes that were
closer to point four ish those are
probably over estimates of the effective
of sodium bicarbonate on muscular
endurance it was probably closer to the
point 2.25 range so so it was quite an
outlier but the results were still
statistically significant without it
it's just you have to keep that in mind
when you interpret that that effect size
now I wanted to go through a couple
other meta analyses from the list really
quick here these are ones that I've
actually reviewed in math I really like
to review metas and masks because I find
meta analyses to be really fascinating
one was about alcohol consumption and
recovery following resistance exercise
and so what what I found most surprising
with this one was that there's actually
a decent number of studies showing no
meaningful effect of like pretty heavy
alcohol consumption when when it comes
to recovery from exercise so like
actually looking at performance recovery
it looks like even
after like some pretty moderate intakes
people can get it together
suck it up and go perform on the
dynamometer you know that they can get
it together which I was a little bit
surprised I thought that the effects on
the actual performance recovery would be
a little bit more dramatic but the
studies that do tend to show impaired
recovery tend to be performed in males
they tend to use particularly strenuous
exercise protocols and they tend to use
higher doses of alcohol and the the
male-female one I don't think that one's
necessarily intuitive but the other two
are quite intuitive right so the idea is
they can suck it up and pull it together
and perform well but it's for like a
pretty basic low volume dynamometer task
right so if it were a skilled sport
performance or a very vigorous full-body
bout of training that might have looked
a little bit different you know
intuitively that that seems correct to
me I mean what about Jordan though I
don't know anything about Jordan count
the Rings baby yeah so yeah I don't I
don't I don't know if we want to use
Michael Jordan's physical athletic feats
as our like well that's a pretty typical
response you know but but another thing
to keep in mind though is that when it
comes to short-term recovery
you know moderate to heavy alcohol
intake does affect things like protein
synthesis sleep quality and a number of
different hormones so even if an
impairment in recovery doesn't show up
on a simple dynamometer II task that
doesn't mean you know okay then like
eight drinks a day from now on that'll
be fine because it will affect protein
synthesis your ability to sleep and
those effects could be cumulative
throughout a training program and like I
said when we start moving the task to
full body exercise or exercise that
requires a great deal of skill and
coordination I don't have a lot of
confidence that those results will still
hold up I think the more strenuous the
activity gets and the more skill that
gets the more likely that you're gonna
suffer a little bit from that heavy
alcohol intake now an important thing to
keep in mind obviously the dose is
critical here one or two drinks I'm
starting to feel real
confident that you know I just can't see
that having a huge impact on training
the next day even with pretty strenuous
workouts in pretty skilled movements if
we're talking about a drink or two but
some of these studies actually use
surprisingly high alcohol doses I mean
most of them do yeah yeah it's a little
bit surprising I think I'm used to just
like assuming the IRB won't let you get
away with anything yeah but like did
some of these were really given some
decent alcohol doses so one thing worth
noting I think for the listeners is that
one of the things that at least like
early studies in a particular area will
do is they'll they'll intentionally
design a study to find an effect because
you know partially you're dealing with
like positive publication bias like if
you find a statistically significant
difference the finding is a little bit
easier to get published generally and
also like you know early research in an
area is kind of like proof-of-concept
work like if we push an idea to an
extreme will it have an impact and then
subsequent research can kind of refine
that where it's like okay like let's
pull back from this extreme a little bit
and see kind of like what this dose
response looks like so a good example of
that I think is the like muscle damage
and recovery research like bro that
that's immediately what came to mind
some of the [ __ ] muscle damage
protocols used in the research are
[Music]
outrageous like I saw one that was like
a hundred straight maximal eccentric
reps on for like knee extension like
dude yeah your quads are gonna be toast
a good example of this was I can't
remember if it was if it was me
extension or elbow flexion it was one of
the two but it was it was like there's
like 50 or so maximally eccentric reps
in completely untrained people and one
of the things they were looking at in
the study was the proportion of I forget
what the exact what
exactly they they termed these subjects
but it was like people who had extreme
responses to it and they defined extreme
responses as if memory serves decrements
in maximal isometric force output of
greater than 70% oh man so you know
we're talking like dude you you
benchpress 300 pounds and by the end of
this test you can no longer put up 90
like that's that's the level of fatigue
we're talking about and it was like if
memory serves I want to say like 30
percent of the female subjects and like
15 percent of the male subjects met that
criteria or criterion and so like dude
that is that is a non-negligible
proportion of the subjects and so you
know this I'm kind of reasoning by
analogy here and we're not reasoning by
analogy but just using this as an
illustration so if you're looking at
like muscle damage research you need to
look at it and think like okay you know
muscle damage is a thing and like this
particular intervention may affect the
time course of recovery but does this
protocol look like how my training might
look and and oftentimes the answer is no
and it's more of like a proof-of-concept
thing and so like treks was saying that
the alcohol literature to this point
a magic that was kind of frustrating to
be one of these researchers like early
on in this area of literature where I
man I remember one study where it was it
was the one that everyone cites about
about alcohol reducing muscle protein
synthesis and I want to say the alcohol
intake amounted to like either 12 or 14
standard drinks on average and it was
just like straight vodka yeah they gave
people either protein vodka or protein
and vodka and like rip to those people
because that had to suck but it was it
was straight
they put them through a pretty grueling
workout and then it's like alright buddy
got to take 14 shots now and like so
yeah that did reduce muscle protein
synthesis but then the question was like
well if it was like three drinks would
it have done anything who's to say and I
feel like I'm rambling but all of all of
this is to say I wonder what it was like
to be one of the early researchers in
this area where it's just like well okay
let's uh let's put people through a
workout let's have them drink ten
standard drinks and then see how their
performance is tomorrow that it's gonna
suck and then it doesn't like dude
they were probably freaking out because
you have to assume those really high
dosages were kind of the alcohol like
analog to a hundred maximal eccentric
reps like the researchers had to be
assuming like oh yeah this is gonna [ __ ]
him up and then it didn't and they were
probably like what the hell is going on
yeah that would just be such a strange
setting to be 14 drinks deep you're just
like I did I can't imagine just being in
a lab full of strangers 14 drinks and
like what that mindset is oh actually
though I just had a thought that is that
is actually maybe on topic and relevant
so in in a recent episode maybe like two
or three back we had a question about
how to prevent hangovers whose only
talked about congener content in alcohol
and how that seems to be related to
likelihood of hangovers and severity of
hangover symptoms one of the things to
note about the alcohol and exercise
literature is I haven't seen one of
these studies that didn't use vodka like
that's that's like the standard okay
we're gonna put someone through a
workout and we're gonna give them
alcohol and see what happens
yeah alcohol of choice and so I wonder
how well these findings generalize to
people who don't just straight up drink
vodka so if you remember from that
episode vodka is if you want to go out
and just get like shit-faced drunk and
not pay for it quite as badly the next
day alcohol
seems to probably be your best choice
just because it has the the lowest
congener content so congeners again our
are kind of outputs of the fermentation
process other than just ethanol so like
butanol methanol etc etc and so like
alcoholic beverages of higher conjuror
contents seem to give you like worse
hangovers the next day and so yeah if
memory serves like literally all of
those studies use vodka and so I mean
like eight shots of vodka and like eight
glasses of red wine very well could have
entirely different effects on on
performance the next day yeah and I just
realized that ya know it's a good point
so yeah it's something to keep in mind
okay moving on there's also a
meta-analysis about carnitine
supplementation looking at exercise
induced muscle damage and recovery from
strenuous exercise and this was another
one I reviewed in mass and and the the
author's reported that soreness was
significantly reduced by L carnitine
supplementation at all the time points
measured so zero 24 48 72 and 96 hours
after a strenuous bout of exercise they
also reported some effects on creatine
kinase myoglobin lactate dehydrogenase
as well
now i reran the meta-analysis a little
bit differently because i thought it was
important to account for the correlated
measurements within in an individual
study and also to model the time effect
from 0 to 24 to 48 and so on and so I
did the meta-analysis a little bit
differently and if you're curious about
how different that went you can check
out the mass issue that that's in but
after rerunning it looks like you know
only soreness and creatine kinase were
really like significantly impacted in my
opinion and it was really only for those
first 48 hours post exercise so my
analysis was a lot more conservative
and the results weren't quite as
dramatic and you know it's open to
interpretation you know you it's two
different approaches to how to analyze
the data so I it would not I'm not
saying like they were wrong but
obviously my bias is clear I like my
analysis best you know that's pretty
obvious but something to keep in mind
there is that the effect on soreness was
enough to lower subjectively reported
soreness by like 1.5 points on a scale
from zero to ten so you know instead of
if they're say hey how sore are you
feeling instead of saying a nine you
would say a seven point five right so
not negligible but not necessarily
dramatic it's kind of kind of subjective
in terms of how much that matters to you
but an important thing to keep in mind
is is that the literature looking at
karna teens effects on on these outcomes
and really a lot of a carnitine
literature in general very very
inconsistent there's a lot of
inconsistencies a lot of heterogeneity
where you see like oh this study
reported a pretty notable effect in this
study had nothing at all there are some
very divergent patterns in the
literature looking at carnitine effects
on like I said just about everything
there there's research looking at karna
teens effects on performance
I think muscle growth looking at fat
loss looking at glycemic control so like
insulin blood glucose and there's just a
great deal of inconsistency so I'm a
little bit hesitant to say oh yeah
carnitine for soreness and recovery
definitely go for it I have some
reservations because of that
inconsistency and I also have
reservations because I think there are
better supplementation candidates out
there you know I'm kind of a broken
record about this but in my opinion if
you really wanted to take something to
try to mitigate some of that post
exercise soreness I think probably a
really good option would be some kind of
really
phyto nutrient rich antioxidant rich
extract coming from something like
pomegranate or watermelon or a beetroot
you
one of these kind of more plant-based
extracts or juices that just tends to be
packed with a ton of antioxidants but
also a ton of different phytonutrients
the other than than antioxidants as well
so I just think you can get more from
your recovery supplement than just
saying oh I'll take carnitine alone when
you've got these other supplementation
candidates which frankly you can also
just get from food which is a good
option but there's these other recovery
candidates where you're like okay this
will probably help my soreness but bring
all these other potential benefits with
it when it comes to ergogenic effects
and better recovery effects as well okay
I've got one more and this is a little
bit of a sneak peak because this is a
meta-analysis that I am it's it's gonna
be coming out oh wait no this episode
goes up July 2nd so my mass article is
gonna go up July 1st so this is not a
sneak peak
you look so yeah yeah I I was thinking
we were gonna be publishing this episode
next week no it's gonna be in two weeks
correct we're now recording next week
because surprise announcement well you
know this Linds and I are bright are
buying our first house yeah which is fun
and cool so dear listeners if I start
expressing more just like booj wah trash
sentiment on this podcast
after becoming a property owner don't
let me get away with it that is uh it's
not good yeah so anyway that this is I
wrote a mass article about this going up
July 1st which when you're listening to
this will be yesterday but it's a
meta-analysis looking at the effects of
arginine supplementation on athletic
performance and what they did was they
looked at the effects of arginine on
what they categorized as aerobic
outcomes and what they categorized as
anaerobic outcomes and so the the the
results indicated that there was like a
pretty big effect for aerobic outcomes
the effect size was 0.8 for which is I
mean like arginine if you've been
following the nitric oxide based
literature you're like yeah arginine its
effect is like maybe slightly better
than nothing but it generally
not super great so I saw 0.84 and I was
like that is surprising and yeah and
then the effect on anaerobic outcomes
was a little bit more down to earth it
was 0.24 but again that's like that's
like right about equal with the
citrulline malate literature but if you
look at any of the research on the topic
any intro or discussion section is gonna
be like yeah we used to care about
arginine we don't anymore we got
citrulline we're better off for it you
know yeah and to be clear like isn't the
biggest reason people don't care much
about arginine anymore like isn't the
main reason that like 80% of it that you
take is sequestered by the gut and
doesn't actually reach systemic
circulation you'll get some different
estimates about the exact percentage
when it comes to the bioavailability and
how much of it gets you know broken down
in the gut and through first pass
metabolism but the short answer is yes
so you take an oral dose of arginine and
there is a substantial amount of
arginine that gets utilized or broken
down before it ever gets to the
bloodstream and so the whole purpose of
arginine supplementation for performance
theoretically is to increase to increase
blood arginine levels so that it can
promote nitric oxide production and what
we found in the research is that if you
take a dose of citrulline you'll
actually increase blood arginine levels
more efficiently and more effectively
than if you took oral arginine instead
and so for a lot of people is kind of an
open-and-shut case the the performance
data for citrulline are a little bit
more promising mechanistically it's
really difficult to to overcome that and
say like oh well yeah citrulline has
great bioavailability arginine doesn't
it's kind of just like what why would
you why would you go with the arginine
it's just really difficult to justify so
I'm not going to give away all of the
juicy details that you can find in the
mass article because it would take a
while but but basically I'd there were
some issues and I'm just gonna there
were some issues there were some effect
sizes that weren't calculated correctly
and so I get into the details of it you
know I was gonna recalculate it but
there were a lot of issues and and I
thought it was best to just kind of
leave it and and
look at some of the reasons why those
effect sizes looked so big but the real
take-home point is that they aren't that
big and so it's one of those things
where when you look at a meta analysis
it's important to read it just as
critically as when you read an original
piece of research right so you can't
just I know I mentioned this before you
can't just say well it's a meta analysis
so I know it's good and I know that this
is the real effect size you know I think
people have gotten into the practice of
very critically reading individual
research articles but you have to have
that same that same perspective with
meta analyses and say wow this effect
size is way bigger than I thought you
have to be open to and say man maybe I
had maybe I just completely misread the
pulse of this literature but you also
have to say is it possible that maybe
some of these effect sizes aren't quite
accurate you know yeah I mean when a
non-negligible proportion of the
researchers in our field don't have the
statistical toolkit to just do like
traditional research well they sure as
hell don't have the statistical toolkit
to perform a meta analysis properly yeah
right but anyway the take-home point is
if you see this if you see this meta
analysis and you're like wow that's very
surprising maybe I should try arginine I
would encourage you not to I just I
don't think there's really much promise
when it comes to arginine
supplementation I think we I think we
have plenty of literature to say if you
find that line of research to be
compelling a much more promising option
will be going with citrulline citrulline
malate or some kind of nitrate based
supplement okay I had a couple other met
metas there but I think we probably
ought to move on to the QA get some of
those in works for me cool so I've got a
quick one here that I'm just gonna read
for myself I basically had two questions
this is a pretty common one it was two
people independently who submitted
questions about tuna consumption and so
I know a lot of people like to consume a
decent amount of tuna canned tuna
because it's convenient it's usually a
pretty affordable protein source
compared to some others and so I know
it's by
like you know you're on a tight budget
you're in college or in a dorm room you
don't have like a full kitchen access so
a canned protein source that's pretty
affordable very attractive option for
sure
but the question was you know you hear
about tuna and potential potentially
high mercury levels in it and the
question was like well how much can I
really get away with on a weekly basis
and so like I feel I'm inclined to just
kind of lean on the FDA's guidance on
that like I I don't claim to have
expertise when it comes to like toxicity
of heavy metals or anything like that so
I usually just lean on unpublished
guidelines for that type of thing and so
I can tell you what the FDA says and if
you have no interest in their opinion
then you can tune this out for a couple
minutes but the way they categorize is
serving what a disclaimer I don't know
just feel free to ignore if you're a
science denier sure but anyway so they
call a serving for an adult four ounces
you know it's about the size of your
palm if you're looking at a little cut
of meat so what what they do is they
categorize it into best choices good
choices and choices to avoid when it
comes to fish consumption and so there
are different kinds of tuna so the best
choices there is one one variety of tuna
it says tuna canned light so that's in
the best choices category but one of the
things that's really interesting is the
best choices category for fish intake
they recommend two to three servings a
week so like you know some of the people
I've seen people online who are like hey
I eat three cans of tuna a day should I
cut back to two a day and it's like more
probably closer to two a week it would
be a more comfortable number you know so
so that's something to keep in mind is
that they're kind of top-end for the
good choices they're recommending two to
three servings a week the good choices
which they say one serving a week would
be would be advisable they do have a
tuna variety it says albacore slash
white tuna and they also have yellowfin
tuna in that good choices category in
the choices to avoid category with the
highest
mercury levels their recommendation is
like just kind of don't eat it unless
you you really have to it like if you do
eat it it's probably like a you know
once in a while kind of thing not like a
staple in your weekly diet they put
bigeye tuna in the choices to afford to
avoid category so that you know like I
said I'm not a heavy metals toxicity
expert I don't really have a lot of
nuance to add to that but a lot of times
people ask about that question and that
in my opinion is kind of the simplest
simplest guidance to give on that
alright so you've got a question here
yeah so there were there were probably a
dozen people who've asked over the last
three months questions about is it okay
to split workouts up throughout the day
versus doing them all in one session you
know basically people are at homes more
their gyms are closed and so they're
like okay I'm cooped up all day I want
to do some sort of training at home and
you know is it fine if I just do like a
set or two every 30 minutes versus doing
all of my training and like a compressed
like hour hour and a half of time and
like yeah that's fine so I think in
general splitting workouts up into
multiple sessions or even like spacing
it all throughout a day is likely to
have a neutral to positive effect it
could it could potentially have a
negative effect if basically you you use
that as an excuse to massively increase
training volume because you don't
accumulate a bunch of fatigue in a
concentrated period of time and so you
just kind of go crazy with it but
assuming you're not doing that it
probably has a neutral to positive
effect so the early studies looking at
the effects of like one a day workouts
versus two a day workouts were performed
on soccer players and weight lifters by
häkkinen and Hartmann respectively and
those studies had some pretty promising
results
not all of the differences were
statistically significant but there were
some significant differences leaning in
favor of multiple daily sessions versus
just one and again this is talking about
like doing the same volume but splitting
it up not doing multiple sessions as a
way to increase volume and so yeah they
they found some differences
statistically in favor of splitting it
up into multiple workouts some non
significant differences that kind of
leaned in favor of splitting it up into
multiple workouts and so pretty
promising results overall there have
been some a handful of more recent
studies in the area including one from
about two years ago by Shia or she ow
that that haven't found any any any
statistically significant or even like
notable non significant effects one way
or the other so overall this body of
research like I said kind of leans
neutral to positive if you split your
workouts up into multiple daily sessions
it may have a small beneficial effect on
strength and possibly hypertrophy or it
may be similarly effective to just doing
it all in one session like I said unless
you use this as an excuse to massively
increase volume to the point that you
can't recover from it I don't really see
it having any negative effects but you
know probably don't expect a
night-and-day difference from it that
makes sense all right next question for
you treks from Nicola Nicola asks how
does hypothalamic amenorrhea affect
hypertrophy if eating at maintenance or
surplus does hypothalamic amenorrhea
still have a negative impact on muscle
building and athletic performance so
this is a really good question and I
think hypothalamic is really the key
word here so a lot of times people focus
on the amenorrhea portion and they say
okay well due to low energy availability
and high exercise volumes
you know I either have completely lost
my menstrual cycle or it's become quite
irregular and so people
to view it in many cases as whether or
not a normal menstrual cycle is present
but I think the time course of recovery
is a little bit more nuanced than that
so there are a number of studies that
are kind of interventions aimed at
restoring normal menstrual cycles in
female athletes who have experienced
hypothalamic amenorrhea and those
interventions intuitively the approach
is quite simple right we need to get
back to a more appropriate level of
energy availability and we need to have
a more moderate approach to training
intensity and volume and so what what's
interesting is in the course of those
studies I think the the outcome if you
just view it from the perspective of did
the the normal menstrual cycle returned
a lot of those studies tend to fail but
that doesn't necessarily mean that there
weren't positive things that occur in
the process right so you can have some
aspects of recovery present without
fully restoring a normal menstrual cycle
so you can have a restoration of some of
your performance some of your ability to
to achieve hypertrophy in the process
just from you know taking control of
training volume again getting energy
available energy availability into a
more suitable range so so it's kind of
tricky and and what I would say is when
we look at hypothalamic amenorrhea like
I said hypothalamic is the key word and
when we see really low energy
availability in place the effects on the
hypothalamus lead to some pretty
widespread downstream effects so we see
alterations in growth hormone igf-1
testosterone estrogen thyroid hormones
it's kind of an entire hormonal milieu
from the top down from the hypothalamus
in response to this low energy
availability and we see effects on the
ability to gain muscle obviously this
isn't an ideal anabolic environment also
not an ideal environment for just
general performance I think and so if
you can restore energy availability to a
better spot and kind of get that up into
a better range I think it's very light
Leon I'm being a bit speculative here
but I think it's very likely that yet
you can start to reverse some of the
difficulties associated with
hypothalamic amenorrhea so I think you
might be able to see some of those you
know those shorter term improvements in
performance and the ability to induce
body composition changes maybe before
you get a full restoration of a normal
menstrual cycle so restoring a normal
menstrual cycle tends to be highly
variable from person to person and the
interventions even with really extreme
interventions there's a lot of
variability for when it doesn't doesn't
work so there's interventions where they
they take a really extreme approach and
on top of you know the dietary and the
exercise modifications they also inject
leptin and even with some pretty extreme
measures like that the restoration of
the menstrual cycle the time course and
just plainly whether or not it actually
worked
it was extremely variable from person to
person so I would say if you're like in
like if you have hypothalamic amenorrhea
and you have not addressed the training
volume and intensity issues and you have
not addressed the energy availability
issues it's very likely that your
performance and your ability to induce
hypertrophy are going to be impaired to
some extent but if you've taken some of
those steps when it comes to adjusting
exercise habits and adjusting energy
availability I think it's quite possible
that you can start restoring some of
those things back to a more normal level
so in the short-term ya hypothalamic
amenorrhea not great for hypertrophy
because of that series of hormonal
effects of it but as you start to
restore those I think you can start to
restore the ability to perform at your
best and induce hypertrophy ok Greg what
do you got next here so a question from
Grimes asking how should we approach
kids and adolescents and resistance
training how young is too young are
there additional safety concerns when it
comes to growth plates and if so what
adjustments to training can be made to
avoid injuring them should heavy singles
for the high percent of 1rm be avoided
and are there any other guidelines
around
topic so I would recommend checking out
a recent review paper by Allison Myers
title of which is resistance training
for children and adolescents and so I'm
gonna address the question about like
safety and growth plates first because I
think that is especially like parents
primary concern and answering that
question isn't entirely straightforward
so a common line you'll hear from like
quote unquote evidence-based fitness
professionals is like oh they used to
say that training would stunt your
growth but we now know that that is
wrong and I don't think that's entirely
true so this is this is an absence of
evidence versus evidence of absence
question so there is no evidence that I
am aware of that lifting that that
children are adolescents lifting weights
will stunt their growth however I am
also not aware of like super strong
conclusive evidence demonstrating that
resistance training won't stunt their
growth and I think that's an important
distinction I personally don't think it
it's gonna stunt their growth and the
research that's on the topic we're you
know let's say you have a three month or
a six month study and you have a group
performing resistance training versus a
group that doesn't and it's you know at
kit with kids or adolescents of an age
where one would still be expecting
growth to occur over those three months
or six months or even up to a year it
seems like growth in a resistant strain
versus non resistance training group is
pretty similar to have say like really
conclusive evidence what one would hope
for would be like you know you have a
group of kids that starts training at
like seven years old and that goes all
the way through until they're like 18 or
19 and you have a group that doesn't do
any resistance training and you look to
see do they wind up the same height like
that's the sort of conclusive evidence
that one would need to be like super
highly confident that lifting doesn't
stun growth that study doesn't exist
I I don't know if it will ever exist but
what I will say is that there is no
evidence currently to suggest that
lifting stunts growth which I think
probably isn't as like strong of a pro
lifting statement as a lot of our
audience would hope that I would give
but hey it's the state of the research
as it is baby you can deal with it so in
terms of of like mechanistically so this
person asked about like injuries to
growth plates and and I think this is
where like the the fear that lifting
might stunt growth started where they're
they're like okay so bone elongation
occurs at growth plates and if you put
high forces on these growth plates maybe
that's gonna damage them and therefore
decrease rate of bone elongation and
therefore stunt people's growth and I'm
not aware of any evidence that that
happens with resistance training and in
fact I would be very surprised if that
happened with resistance training just
because like dude if you want to talk
about forces on bones the forces that
bones are undergoing with resistance
training are so much smaller than just
like kids running and jumping and doing
kids stuff like dude I remembered I
remember vaguely being like you know
three three four years old and just
seeing like what the tallest thing I
could jump off of without hurting myself
was like that was putting way higher
forces on my bones than like doing a max
deadlift at that age would have you know
and so like yeah dude if kids just like
running and jumping and jumping off of
stuff and being kids isn't damaging
growth plates like lifting weights
probably wouldn't as well if you do have
a growth plate fracture that can just
like completely stop bone growth and
that's that's not good like if you had a
growth plate fracture and one femur and
not the other one legs just gonna wind
up way longer than the other like that
that is pretty serious business but in
terms of like for
is on growth plates being sufficient to
damage them with resistance training
especially in children and adolescents
like that's that's just on its face
implausible so you probably don't need
to worry about that in terms of things
kind of like best practices one is just
like kids always need to be monitored in
the weight room because you know there
is the potential for injury there's
always the potential for injury with
everyone but you know kids just
generally don't have as good of a as
good of an attention span as adults do
they often don't have quite as good of
body control and if you're training kids
in like a group setting they may be you
know like let's say for whatever reason
you're doing like youth weightlifting
training if you're doing weight lifting
training with people in their 20s and
someone's like doing snatches or clean
and jerks everyone's aware of who's
throwing weight over their head and
we're not two step if you don't want to
get a bar dropped on you like [ __ ]
eight-year-olds probably aren't so you
know you need to be really observant
about that and just like the types of
weight room injuries that come from lack
of attention like dropping weights on
people and dropping plates on your own
foot etc like that stuff's probably way
more common with kids than it would be
with older adolescents and certainly
adults so you need to be super cognizant
of that sort of weight room injury and
then when it comes to how you actually
train kids until until they hit puberty
you should probably mostly be focusing
on generally developing skills so both
like athletic skills and also weight
room skills so make sure they have good
control of their body and the exercises
that they're doing you're you're
focusing intently on are they performing
the exercise properly versus are you
loading them up with a lot of weight so
motor skills are way more plastic and
you can learn them way faster when when
people are young so that is like the
ideal time to teach them how to
to properly perform exercises and in
terms of the outcomes of training you
know going super close to failure and
using super heavy weights like the juice
just isn't worth the squeeze with with
children and like young adolescents just
because like the strength and
hypertrophy effects aren't as great so
the research looking at resistance
training interventions in like kids and
early adolescence before like really
hitting puberty hard versus like during
and post puberty tends to indicate that
if you put them on the same training
program the strength and hypertrophy
effects during and after puberty are
substantially greater than before
puberty so before puberty you know
teaching them technique work on weight
room skills and then once puberty really
starts kicking in then if you want to
start ramping up loads more ramping up
volume more training them a little bit
closer to failure you know one hopefully
they should be prepared for it by then
because you've been kind of laying the
groundwork with skill development to
that point and to they'll they'll just
be able to derive larger benefits from
it kind of once puberty is online so
yeah those those would be my general
recommendations and yeah the biggest
thing as far as injuries go it's like
just keep a super close eye on everyone
and make sure that make sure that you
drill technique over and over and over
again before adding any substantial
amount of external load all right good
stuff based on the time I think we
should probably jump ahead to our
rapid-fire questions I want to just go
through you know we get a lot of
questions submitted to us some of them
require quite a lengthy explanation but
there have been a number of questions
where I'm like it I'll answer that in
like a couple sentences and so I've got
a little list I want to go through here
just because you know we want the
listeners to get their questions
answered but some of these don't really
make it into the show is like a big
ten-minute thing we're going to talk
about so I'm just going to go through
some of mine here one was is it likely
that habitual intake of nitrate rich
vegetables such as beets and spinach and
really any
leafy green can those induce the same
organic benefits as like a highly
concentrated supplement with nitrate and
the answer is hell yeah definitely I
recommend that actually because if you
look at some of the independent research
on a lot of the beetroot supplement
products on the market there are
actually some notable quality concerned
quality control concerns in terms of the
actual nitrate dose that's present in
some of those because I mean nitrates
tricky like even in even in just like
produce you can get a great deal of
variability so it's hard to know the
exact dose you're getting I think a very
reasonable response to that is to just
generally eat a diet with plenty of
nitrate rich vegetables in it
but there's direct research on this so
it's not just kind of speculative there
was a study by Fleck and colleagues in
2016 where they looked at whether or not
beetroot juice was more effective than
than a nitrate matched dose of sodium
nitrate and they did find that there was
a slight difference but but but the
beetroot juice actually was a little bit
a little bit more had slightly better
effects than sodium nitrate alone so one
of the things I find interesting about
going the food route is that you're not
just getting nitrate content but
whichever food you're going with you're
typically going to get a number of other
antioxidants in that are just naturally
occurring in the food matrix and there
there can be some synergistic effects
between the antioxidants and the food
matrix and the nitrate itself of course
in that study they use beetroot juice
which is a supplement but the same thing
would apply to whatever food source you
might use and there was another study by
Clifford and colleagues that found the
same thing where the beetroot juice was
a little bit more effective than the
sodium nitrate itself so some of these
other compounds in the foods and the
juices you might use are cantrip
contributing and a non-negligible way
and there was a study I can't remember
the name of the author off the top of my
head but there was a study where they
actually tried to do an intervention
where they said instead of giving you a
nitrate supplement we're going to
encourage you to eat this list of foods
that's higher in nitrate and what they
showed in that study was
there were positive effects associated
with the intervention but the
intervention itself was effective at
increasing nitrate intake enough to get
up into those organic ranges that we see
with supplementation so the really nice
thing about nitrate is we it's very
realistic to eat enough foods rich in
nitrate feeds and and food derived
juices that you could get the type of
dose we would deliver with a supplement
that's a pretty unique thing for a lot
of supplements and the even cooler thing
is you have a much better idea of
exactly what your nitrate content might
be if you have a diverse array of
nitrate rich foods you don't have to
worry about just getting a supplement
that's a total dud you can kind of
diversify that a little bit and the
foods are likely to have some other
phytonutrients present in the food that
have either a neutral or positive effect
on the action of the nitrate that you're
taking in so not only is it okay to go
with with you know foods and beverages
rather than some of these supplements
but you could argue in some cases is
actually a more favorable way to go and
depending on what supplement you're
going with another question I got it was
about l-citrulline basically should I be
taking it is there a best time to take
it what kind of dosing strategies are
advisable so if you're going to go the
l-citrulline route the the standard dose
you're going to see in the literature is
between three and six grams a day you
might as well err on the safe side and
go with the six grams in my opinion if
you're going citrulline malate rather
than l-citrulline though that's usually
dosed at six to eight grams and the
ratio of citrulline to malate is usually
one to one or two to one however there
was a study that actually tested that
like to verify those label claims they
were not what you would call accurate
they weren't way off but even the ones
that claimed to be two to one were more
like one and a half to one but but in
any case what I would recommend with
citrulline malate is generally going
with the two to one ratio of citrulline
omalley whether or not that's the exact
ratio and probably going with the eight
gram dose just to make sure you're
getting plenty of citrulline out of it
one of the questions was just timing
matter and generally I would take it all
in one dose
rather than splitting it up and I would
take that dose around one to two hours
before exercise the studies showing
gurga genic benefits when it comes to
strength and power outcomes they
typically give it an hour before
training or before exercise testing
theoretically looking at the
pharmacokinetics you could justify that
two hours should be just as effective as
one hour anywhere in the one to two hour
range should be fine
but if you want to go with like okay the
the studies that have looked at one hour
and two hour dosing in the same study
there's certainly no benefit to going
with two hours instead of one and if you
want to just make it simple and say okay
the studies that work what are they
doing it's usually giving 6 to 8 grams
of citrulline malate and it's usually
giving it an hour before exercise so I
would not split it up throughout the day
and that's probably the the dosing that
I'd go with and again it's important to
have realistic expectations we're
talking about a pooled effect size of
about point two that's a nice thing but
it's not something that's going to
completely revolutionize your training
question from Mike about the optimal
speed for consumption of a protein bolus
should you chug your protein shake drink
it slowly drink half of it fast then sip
it doesn't matter so so when it comes to
protein timing this is something we've
discussed many times on the show I think
it's advisable to split your daily
protein in two I would say somewhere
between three and five bonuses
throughout the day the exact speed of
consumption doesn't matter because you
know the term that Helm's always uses is
the conga line analogy where like we've
got these bolus is kind of working
through our digestive system one after
another and any kind of precision we
think that we're applying when it when
it's in the context of a mixed meal that
has fiber that's altering the digestion
rate it has fat altering the digestion
rate the bulk of food in the GI tract
there's a lot of different contextual
factors that even if we wanted to
micromanage that speed of bolus
consumption it's simply out of our hands
at that point there are too many other
factors associated with the rate of
digestion and the rate at which those
amino acids are going to appear in the
blood so a simple answer the the rate at
which you're consuming those
Alissa's doesn't matter but I do think
it makes sense to have somewhere between
three and five relatively equal size
protein boluses throughout the day
another protein question from from Adam
asking about high-protein diets and
potentially a link to kidney stones and
so this is something I looked into you
know if you're a healthy person a lot of
times people talk about kidney failure
or kidney disease with high protein
diets if you have an underlying kidney
issue you know such as like advanced
kidney disease or something like that
then they will tell you you shouldn't be
on a high protein diet and that's very
much true but a lot of times people
misinterpret that thinking if I have a
healthy kidney and I go on a
high-protein diet I'm going to give
myself kidney disease or something like
that
the evidence is not consistent with that
thought process at all you know a person
with a healthy kidney should be able to
accommodate a high protein diet quite
effectively within the ranges that we've
actually studied in terms of protein
intake and we've studied some pretty
pretty wide ranges so when it comes to
kidney stones there are a few different
types of kidney stones that are made out
of slightly different things and there
certainly are looking into it there are
mechanistic reasons that you might at
least be concerned about it like you
could say okay well if I consumed a high
protein diet increases urinary excretion
of this and this could increase the
likelihood of kidney stone formation the
the mechanistic connections are there
but when you look at the more recent
updates in the literature it seems like
the consensus for now is if you're a
person who is predisposed to kidney
stone formation it might be something to
take a look at you might want to look at
your total amount of protein and the
types of protein that you're taking in
specifically but if you're a person with
healthy kidneys and you have no
predisposing factors you're not someone
who is kind of naturally prone to kidney
stone formation it doesn't seem like
there's enough evidence to suggest that
going on a high-protein diet would make
you more prone to having kidney stones
it's one of those things where if the
pathology is present is present or the
the susceptibility is present before the
diet then it might be something with
there might be some connections there
but for a healthy kidney with no
predisposing factors and no kind of
underlying pathology it doesn't seem
like that link is conclusively drawn in
the research and right now like I said
the consensus seems to be probably not a
big deal but if you if you develop
kidney stones then you might want to
take a look at your protein intake and
the types of protein that you're
consuming and then finally a question
about l-theanine supplementation so
we've talked about l-theanine in the
past one of the cool things about it is
l-theanine there's some evidence
indicating it helps with relaxation but
but it's not sedative in nature so a lot
of times people will pair it with
caffeine because it kind of for a lack
of a better term take the edge off of
the caffeine kind of reduce some of the
jitteriness and sometimes people get a
little bit more anxious when they have
high caffeine doses so it should be able
to attenuate some of those effects of
caffeine some of those unfavorable
things that that some people experience
but it shouldn't make you sleepy in the
process so it's a really nice supplement
to complement caffeine anyone that
listens to the show knows that Gregg and
I are big caffeine fans but like I do
like to every now and then supplement
theanine just to kind of take some of
that off you know especially if I'm
taking really high doses of caffeine I
think theanine complements that really
well in terms of the dosing usually a
hundred to 200 milligrams should be fine
with your caffeine dose I do know some
people that it's almost like when they
take higher theanine doses i've talked
to people anecdotally who say that they
almost feel sleepy even though there's
not a sedative effect they just kind of
I think they subjectively tie that
sensation in that that kind of
relaxation they tie that in with with
sedation and sleepiness so they they
note that they kind of subjectively feel
a little bit more sleepy and so if
that's you then it's not for you but but
if you take high doses of caffeine and
you tend to get a little bit more
jittery or anxious it's something that
might not hurt to try and like I said
the dosing typically down around 100 or
200 milligrams should do it alright I
have a handful of rapid-fire questions
as well first is from
Daffy Duck mr. duck thank you for
listening
Greg it's been 5 years since he wrote
the belt Bible what if anything has
changed is it time for a rehashing on
the subject of the power lifting belt
answer to that is no not really so
2014-2015 I published an article on
stronger by science titled the belt
Bible that went through all of the
research at the time on power lifting
belts there hasn't really been anything
super noteworthy published since then
with the exception of one study in 2018
that was looking at kind of like
mechanistically does increased
intra-abdominal pressure increase
people's maximum capacity to exert hip
extension torque and it turned out it
did in that study they weren't they
weren't using belts they were you know
just using like various breathing
techniques in the valsalva to induce
differences in intra-abdominal pressure
but they did find that as
intra-abdominal pressure increased
maximal voluntary hip extension torque
also increased and so that provides a
plausible mechanism by which belts could
work that that's important because in
the original article I
I basically mentioned the fact that like
okay here's like maybe a reason belts
could work like maybe an increased
intra-abdominal pressure just allows
your spine to to not to anthropomorphize
it too much but I'm gonna
anthropomorphize it helps it feel safe
and secure and therefore kind of allows
muscles
you know downstream to be able to exert
more force feeling they're like okay the
spine safe everything else can kind of
fire on on all cylinders but you know
that was that was just conjecture and
not too long before writing that article
stu mcgill wrote a piece saying that
like the way by which belts could work
is if like spinal flexion occurs and
something about like the the
moments exerted by the belt in the
presence of spinal flexion allows people
to lift more but if you're not flexing
your spine
wearing a belt shouldn't help with
maximal force output and I was just like
yeah you know what with all due respects
to Miguel you know way more about the
spine than I do but that strikes me as
implausible because even when I don't
flex my spine I feel like I can lift
more with the belt maybe I'm crazy
though so anyway that that 2018 study
helps helps counter that point to some
degree showing that like you know in in
lab conditions just increasing
intra-abdominal pressure does increase
hip extension torque so that kind of
adds another piece to the puzzle and and
gives a little bit more mechanistic
underpinnings for why belts might be
effective for increasing force output
but yeah other than that like nothing
has really changed in the literature I
do not think that article is in need of
an overhaul one article that is in need
of an overhaul though is one I wrote
titled grow like a new lifter again that
talks about my nuclear domain theory
there was a cool review on that that
came out recently it's going to be in
the upcoming issue of mass you know that
content now is for mass subscribers but
I will talk about that on the site at
some point and will overhaul that
article eventually but yes there there
are articles on the site that are due
for an overhaul but the Bell Bible is
not one of them
moving on Victor asks does asita silicic
acid parenthesis aspirin blunt
hypertrophy or strength gains and my
answer to Victor is I don't know however
it plausibly could so insets
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs
including ibuprofen and naproxen have
been shown to inhibit hypertrophy in
healthy young subjects they they might
actually improve hypertrophy in older
subjects or subjects with just like
higher baseline levels of inflammation
basically they're like
and in the inflammatory response in
hypertrophy seems to have like a pretty
hormetic response where if someone has
low baseline levels of inflammation and
they take high doses of insets that
knocks their inflammation levels down to
low for optimal hypertrophy signaling or
as if someone's elderly or has higher
inflammation levels bringing their
levels of inflammation down back into
kind of the optimal hormetic range can
actually improve hypertrophy but yeah
for most people in cut off part of
Victor's question but basically he's a
he's a young healthy power lifter
yeah so in SEDs in that population at
high enough doses probably do decrease
hypertrophy to some degree that's
important background because asita silic
acid or aspirin is not an in said
however they do work via similar
mechanisms and the mechanism by which
aspirin works may actually make it
slightly worse for hypertrophy than
NSAIDs
so in SEDs are primarily reversible
cox-2 inhibitors cox-2 is stands for
cyclooxygenase - that is an enzyme that
is kind of like the the bottleneck of
the inflammatory response so stuff
happens upstream of the cox enzymes and
then they're kind of like activated and
then their downstream effects are the
inflammatory response one gets after
training injury muscle damage they're
kind of like the master switch for a lot
of inflammatory processes and you have
cox-1 and cox-2 insides don't seem to
have much of an effect on cox-1 but they
are reversible cox-2 inhibitors aspirin
is also a reversible cox-2 inhibitor and
is also an irreversible cox-1 inhibitor
it's probably not worth getting into all
of the details in terms of like how the
different cyclooxygenase is differ and
like what what the slightly different
downstream effects are but aspirin does
irreversibly inhibits cox-1 and does
also have
similar reversible cox-2 inhibitions
which which again is the primary
mechanism of NSAIDs so I would think if
incense effects on uncocks to inhibition
are the primary reason that they inhibit
hypertrophy I would think that aspirin
would also inhibit hypertrophy at high
enough dosages because it's also a
reversible cox-2 inhibitor the fact that
it is an irreversible cox-1 inhibitor
and could therefore maybe decrease the
inflammatory response even further might
actually make it in even slightly worse
choice than NSAIDs for for hypertrophy
and for lifters but but that's just my
assumption based on very rough
mechanisms like I said I'm not a hundred
percent sure because it hasn't shown up
in the literature so most of the studies
that look at this stuff do use ibuprofen
or naproxen so I'm not I can't say with
a hundred percent confidence that
reasonably high doses of aspirin would
inhibit hypertrophy but I fear and
suspect that they might and that's about
the best answer I can give and then
finally there's a question from Tom Tom
asks does being younger so for example
16 to 19 years old affect strength
negatively I'm a younger lifter and
found that I couldn't use standard
linear progression to reach a 405
deadlift which is supposedly
intermediate so first to answer like the
text of the question does does being
younger affect strength negatively as I
alluded to previously puberty matters
and people hit puberty and and you know
physically mature at different rates by
19 years old you should you should
definitely be on the other side of
puberty or at least like in it and very
late and it if you if you are a late
bloomer by 16 it's kind of up in the air
like most people are probably going to
be well into puberty by that point some
people may just be entering puberty but
yeah bye-bye 60
17 you should probably be to the age
where you do respond pretty well to
resistance training where you can gain
strength and muscle pretty well so you
know if you ask this question like hey
I'm 13 years old and the answer might be
a little different by 16 to 19 yeah you
should be able to gain muscle and
strength pretty well but kind of like
the subtext of this question is Tom
isn't isn't super enthused about his
progress so far he tried to do a
standard linear progression and stalled
out at some point before a 405 deadlift
which some website told him was like
intermediate level like you should be
able to get there on a linear
progression when you first start lifting
and like don't worry about that Tom
you're fine so I think one this is
something we talked about on the podcast
all the time people focus way too much
on averages and not enough on kind of
the variability surrounding those
averages and then also like terminology
like the way people use terms like
novice intermediate advanced I think is
just utter and complete [ __ ] kind of
secondary to the point about variability
so like yeah I think it's very plausible
that when people start lifting for the
first time they get on a linear
progression maybe kind of on average
they stall out around a 405 deadlift
initially personally I think that's
actually a little high I don't think the
majority of people get there on a linear
progression but I don't think that's
completely unreasonable for for a number
to shoot for within your first year or
two of lifting if you're a healthy
relatively young male and not like super
super small but like you know don't
worry about it like do your linear
progression take it as far as it'll let
you take it and then when you stall out
that's fine I have seen people stall on
or I've seen male lifters stall on
linear program
put the deadlift at numbers south of 315
and we're talking pounds here
the most extreme example I've seen if
someone just being able to milk the [ __ ]
out of the linear progression is I had a
client one time who came to me and I've
talked about him on the podcast before
but he came to me with if memory serves
a 540 or 550 squat and I just assumed he
had a fair amount of training experience
he filled out the questionnaire to ask
him about his training background what
programs he done previously and he's
like yep I've done eight months of
starting strength you know he came to me
for coaching once he stalled on a linear
progression and that linear progression
shot him out with like a 550 squat so
like yeah dude there's a [ __ ] ton of
variability and wherever you wind up is
fine like as long as you're putting
appropriate effort and focus into your
training things are good
maybe you respond like average maybe you
respond a little bit worse than average
maybe respond considerably better than
average it doesn't matter as long as
you're getting better things are fine
and then the point about language usage
like I think that putting numbers on
what it means to be a novice
intermediate or advanced lifter is just
stupid numbers by numbers I mean like
how much someone can actually lift you
know if you just didn't pick a great
parents for getting strong and you've
put in 10 years under the bar and your
max deadlift is 405 and like you know
you stalled out on a linear progression
it's a 280 and you've had to scratch and
claw your way to a 405 deadlift you know
apply yourself learn a lot in the
process and that's where you are like
you're a [ __ ] advanced lifter you
know like you're not gonna set any
powerlifting records but you are an
advanced lifter like you are like in
your context like that's where you are
and same thing like like my client who
like a linear progression spat him out
with a 550 squat
when his squat was 510 he was a novice
lifter you know like he he handed spent
that much time lifting he wasn't
particularly good at it in terms of like
you know motor skills and technique and
whatnot he was just a [ __ ] strong
dude
so like yet don't if if someone is
telling you like Oh 405 deadlift is the
cutoff for intermediate just ignore them
don't pay attention to anything they say
ever again they have no idea what
they're talking about if you want to use
that terminology I would define a novice
as someone who can make progression like
like measurable progression on their
main lifts on a like weekly or bi-weekly
basis if you can put you know five
pounds or two and a half kilos on the
bar every week or two
I'd still consider you a novice if you
can reliably increase strength on say
like a monthly to by monthly basis like
you've run a four week or an eight week
mesocycle and your lifts reliably go up
you know five ten pounds I'd say you're
an intermediate and past that point
where you need like a full training
cycle and everything to go pretty well
to make measurable progress then I would
consider you an advanced lifter and
whatever actual numbers on the bar those
timelines correspond with completely
irrelevant don't worry about it at all
so to play us out with this episode got
a couple of kind of professional
development questions we've taken these
in the past you know it's usually people
who want to get some information about
their their schooling their education
getting into personal training something
like that or interpreting research as
well so the first question is from
Nathan and Nathan basically is in the
middle of a career change he's becoming
he just recently got certified as a
personal trainer and is currently
pursuing a bachelor's degree in
kinesiology
and the question is basically when does
somebody know when they are ready to
begin taking on clients as a trainer a
little bit of anxiousness a little bit
of uncertainty so
I don't know Greg what do you think when
is somebody ready to start taking on
clients I mean you're probably not so
yeah I mean so I think the education
process for personal trainers in America
I don't know how it is in other
countries is is way less than ideal
because like training people it's a it's
it's an applied thing right like you
need to have some some basic book
knowledge about what effective training
generally looks like but then you also
need the the hands-on skills of being
able to you know spot technique errors
on the fly make like training program
adjustments on the fly if like what you
wrote down initially isn't isn't working
that well for the session building
rapport with people and like being able
to get a good effort out of them like
those those are all skills that you can
only learn by doing and so like in my
opinion in an ideal world there would be
some sort of mentorship component for
personal training certifications where
you know you and I don't I don't even
think it needs to be a particularly long
period of time but like you know you get
you're like you take your test you get
your little certification but then
before you can actually train clients
one-on-one for maybe like two or three
months or so you kind of work under the
wing of someone who's been training
folks for a while they know what they're
doing you observe them in action they
can kind of like let you take some
clients while they observe you to make
sure that that you know what you're
doing and then at the end of the process
hopefully you should you should be
pretty decent like I think that sort of
like mentorship or like apprenticeship
system would be really really ideal for
personal trainers in commercial gym
settings do they typically have I feel
like I've I worked at a commercial gym
where there was a group
personal trainers and there was like a
manager of those trainers and they did
have meetings and stuff do you think
that would serve as a good mechanism of
just kind of like learning on the job
just being able to lean on some of those
colleagues so I think that would I think
that could at least like conceivably
accelerate the learning process so like
like basically I think unless you have
some hands-on experience like your first
few sessions and your first few clients
like you're probably gonna be pretty bad
but yeah with that sort of like internal
gym mechanism in place I think it could
help accelerate the learning process so
like you know maybe by a month in you're
pretty confident and know what you're
doing versus taking like six months to
really get your feet wet and be doing
pretty good work but I still think
initially you're you're probably gonna
be reasonably bad so yeah I mean
unfortunately that's not the system the
current system is what it is like you go
take a test you get a piece of paper
that says you can train other human
beings and yeah like getting that piece
of paper does not at all mean you're
ready to take on clients but the way
pretty much everyone has done it is you
just start and you take on clients and
you try to get better as fast as you can
if if you are at a place where you are
where you're any decent enough financial
position where you could like hit up a
trainer or a gym owner in your area and
say like you know hey I'm working this
other job part-time and like when I'm
not working
can I come like shadow you and you teach
me some stuff that would be great that
would be way above and beyond the call
not many people do that people should do
that but like dude it's it's a hard
economy out there and you know it's not
it's not realistic to expect people to
make that plunge before they actually
start making money as a trainer so if
you could do that that would be
incredible
I'm not we're certainly not saying we
expect that of you but yeah I mean dude
if you just got your if you just got
your
bachelor's in kinesiology you just got
your first cert you're not ready to take
on clients but uh you know you just
start doing it and you get better over
time and that's I think that's about the
the best that is feasible for most
people yeah I really like the idea of if
possible shadowing or even doing like a
brief internship or something like that
just kind of working under somebody
learning from them which now that I
think about it since since Nathan did
get his bachelor's in kinesiology
currently pursuing it or currently
pursuing yes so there may be an
internship facet there and if that's the
case pick your pick your internship
carefully and make sure you're shadowing
someone or in learning from someone in
the type of setting where you would want
to train people and if your college
doesn't have an internship requirement
that's a shame yeah and you you can do a
you know quote unquote internship even
if it's not officially an internship
through a university mechanism you know
if you say hey can I like shadow you and
try to learn some stuff from you some
people might be willing to do that I
would definitely say for me personally
when I first started training people in
person it was really nice because I was
working with a sport team and I was
working under the head strength coach at
that school and so that was a really
nice way to get some coaching skills
without having the full responsibility
of running the entire show you know you
could give some pointers here and there
they could say oh you know you gave this
cue you might want to you might want to
try this cue in the future a different
cue but yeah any kind of experience
where you can work under somebody or
lean on somebody with more experience I
think that would be a nice way to ease
into it and feel a little bit more
comfortable but you know like like Greg
said like you might not actually be
ready but you might be ready enough to
start becoming ready you know by taking
the plunge and you know you might make
some some small mistakes getting started
but you'll develop that comfort level as
you go I think another thing I'd say as
well is like if you get a job
you know like a golds or some sort of
big commercial gym you're not gonna have
a full client roster on day one so you
know another thing you could do is like
after you get that job when you do start
training people hours that you're not
that you don't have clients sessions
scheduled you can ask other trainers
they are with more experience if you
could shadow them so you know that that
might be able to help accelerate your
development on the job because yeah
you're your first couple of months
you're proud it's probably gonna be
pretty lean in terms of of how many like
client sessions you actually have yeah
that's that's really the only thing I
wanted to add cool okay so one more here
from Hannah this is more on the research
side of things so Hannah is a first year
psychology student recently had a class
on how to read research articles they
were given a bunch of papers on topics
and they all kind of had different
advice on how to approach reading
research but but she mentioned that a
lot of them had processes very detailed
processes that were like you know five
or six hours per paper like the process
of going through it carefully and so her
question for us is basically she'd like
to hear how we approach reading research
both when it comes to an individual
paper but also when it comes to like an
entire area of research where we're just
kind of diving in and how our approach
changes based on our goal or our reason
for reading that research do you want to
start yeah I can start so I will say
five to six hours per paper if you are
trying to emerge on the other side with
a full detailed comprehensive
understanding of that paper five to six
hours doesn't sound that implausible to
me right so I wouldn't say like right
off the bat five to six hours that's
crazy I'd say you know it if I were like
you know writing a mass article about a
specific study and I wanted to feel like
I really knew that thing top to bottom
that that probably is about the
timeframe same thing goes I don't
do it anymore but back when I used to
review papers for journals five or six
hours at least because again the goal
there is five to six glorious unpaid
hours exactly but the goal is like
you're supposed to be the gatekeeper
there you're supposed to be the person
who is deciding whether or not this you
know meets the criteria to become part
of the published literature and that's
supposed to mean something Gregg but
it's supposed to but anyway so I mean
honestly I would say when I would do a
review of like a peer-reviewed paper I
would say those would usually take me at
least eight to ten hours at minimum but
but yeah it does vary depending on the
goal now a different different approach
you know if someone asked me a question
about a body of literature that I don't
really need to know all the nuance
they're just like practical take away
what's your sense like what's the vibe
you get from this body of literature if
I can find a meta-analysis on the topic
that was published ideally within the
last five to ten years usually that's a
good way if you can look through the
meta you can get a general sense of what
this body of literature looks like in
aggregate if you can find a couple metas
and they both seem to agree and kind of
triangulate toward the same conclusion
that's usually about as much as I need
to do for if it's a full area of
research that I don't intend to like
create original content about usually
that's the type of thing you can do in a
couple hours just get a good sense of a
recent meta-analysis on the topic and
assuming the meta-analysis was done
reasonably well you should be in pretty
good shape but yeah I mean you know we
have have we put out free content about
how to read research or is that only on
the mass yeah I don't think we have yet
okay but yeah we've talked about it on
the podcast before them we have talked
about it on it's quite a process and
unfortunately it does require a pretty
specialized skill set to some extent you
know you it's difficult to carefully
interpret a method section if you don't
know what the what the methods are so
it's the type of thing where you have to
slow down when you see something you
don't understand
probably do additional reading to figure
out what that is the statistical stuff
is a whole other can of worms that you
know it's I would say I'm quite biased
but I think it's very difficult to
critically appraise research if it's
using statistical methods that you have
fundamentally no understanding what's
going on it's very difficult to look
into that so it's a process that takes a
lot of time to develop that skill set
but I will say this practically speaking
yeah it's gonna take a few hours per
paper most likely but the best way to
get good at it in my opinion is to read
a piece of research develop your own
conclusions about was this good or bad
what was the key finding how useful is
this and then if you can find other
people who are more experienced doing
that same thing for that same paper I
think that can be a really valuable
thing so like if you're scrolling
through you know whatever social media
that you're on you see that somebody
who's really good at this stuff
published a an article about a study
before you read their take on it do your
own read through the study get your own
sense of you know what they did write
what they did wrong and then kind of
cross-reference with you know the
article if the person who's good at this
who has a lot more experience and what I
find is you know just talking to people
that you know who are who are pretty
good at interpreting research if you
continue to share ideas with them and
they continue to point out things you
missed or things you got wrong over time
you kind of create this collection of
mistakes that you'll never make again
and the longer that list gets you know
you start you make every minor mistake
in the book and then all of a sudden you
have this really comprehensive list of
like I can't make these mistakes and
that essentially becomes your list of
things to check when you're reading
research and you develop that skill set
over time yeah what you said there at
the end
resonates with me a lot because that's
pretty much what I did I am I've talked
about this on the podcast before I'm not
a planner I'm very much the type of
person who just rushes headlong into
things and I try not to make mistakes
but
I do like a [ __ ] it learn from it try to
do better next time
and and so like that was basically my
process of getting better at reading
research I thought I knew what I was
talking about
I very much didn't know what I was
talking about I wrote content I put it
out into the world people who knew a lot
more than me were just like what the
[ __ ] dude you're being a dumbass
and then like you know that stinks it's
it's publicly embarrassing and then it's
like well I messed that up
let's not do that again and yes like
dude like the first like three years my
content [ __ ] sucked
and then it just got better because I
had a long list of screw-ups to not do
again so so I think that helps I'm not
necessarily suggesting that everyone
take the approach that I did that would
probably be really bad for the the
general signal-to-noise ratios I
generate a ton of yeah but like whatever
it works for me yeah let's see so in
terms of like directly addressing this
question how long it takes to get
through a paper it kind of depends how
well you understand the area of research
so you know for example if you want to
do a super thorough review of a paper
and it's it's something that you're you
know you have a decent enough context
that you kind of know what's going on
but you're not super familiar with the
research in that area you may you know
it may take you two hours to get through
the method section because you're
running PubMed searches on every piece
of methodology used in that study to see
like okay what did they actually do here
does it seem like it was appropriate or
inappropriate etc when you're reading
the discussion section may take you a
really long time to get through that
because they're comparing and
contrasting their findings to prior
research on similar topics and you're
like well are they representing
prior studies properly let's pull him up
check them out and like yeah that can
that can be a really really long process
and so like dog five or six hours that's
that's incredibly plausible however if
you re research in a in a particular
area for quite a while you might be able
to get that number down to an hour or so
hour and a half because you know if
you're if you're scooting through the
methods section and you've either used
some of the methods before in your own
research or they're methods that you've
seen a lot in Prior research in the area
you know what those methods are you know
if they're appropriate or inappropriate
you know you can just read through the
methods section and you just know if it
was right or not you know or at minimum
you know what was going on like treks
was talking about with stats if you have
a decent grasp of statistics and they
they were using statistical techniques
that you're you know well acquainted
with shouldn't take any time at all to
get through a results section like you
know what they did you know if it was
reported properly or not and if it's an
area of research you're pretty well
acquainted with you can also zip through
the the intro and discussion pretty
quickly because all of the papers that
they're referencing that they're
comparing and contrasting their results
with you've read those papers you know
what went on in those papers and you
don't you know you may want to pull them
up just to refresh your memory but
you're not gonna need to take a lot of
time reading them like and you know you
may even realize like oh this discussion
section was really incomplete there are
a few major papers in this area that
they just didn't cite or grapple with
the findings of at all and so like yeah
if if it's an area that you're pretty
well acquainted with a lot of that stuff
just becomes way quicker over time
because you understand that area of
research and the methods associated with
it way way better so like for example
like dude if I pull up a periodization
study I did a meta-analysis of the
periodization literature for stronger by
science I've read every new
periodization paper that's come out
since then I know the methods people use
for general
since training research it's not gonna
take me any time at all to get through a
new periodization paper but so I
mentioned tDCS earlier in this episode
transcranial direct current stimulation
I'd heard of it I was skeptical of it I
hadn't really read any research on it
and then when there was an interesting
paper about it or at least like the
results looked interesting that I
reviewed for mass maybe like a year ago
and yeah like it it probably took me
five or six hours to work my way through
that paper because I didn't understand
the technology I didn't understand I I
understood the strength testing methods
but not like the the way that one would
go about setting up tDCS the difference
between like a nodal and cathodal
stimulation etc so like it took me a
long time to get through the methods and
do a lot of background reading to see if
what they did was correct and legitimate
or not
it took me a long time to get through
the discussion section because they're
citing all these papers using tDCS that
I haven't read and so I have to go pull
up those papers at least give him a skim
to see what was going on there and yeah
like I'm pretty experienced with reading
and analyzing research but that was that
was something out of left field and I
wasn't you know I I didn't have my feet
wet in that area of literature so it did
take me about five or six hours to get
through the first time I read a tDCS
paper so um yeah dude
if you're reading and analyzing research
well it either doesn't take you a ton of
time because you've already done so much
of it that you have like the background
knowledge in a niche built up already
that you can that you can mow through it
a little bit quicker or if it's
something that's not super familiar with
you it it does take a while and it
should take a while yeah I think one of
the interesting things is the parallels
between this and the previous question
which is like if you're waiting around
for that special time when you're gonna
be fully prepared to do a perfect job
whether it's beginning training or
beginning with interpreting research
it's just not going to happen
you know it's you got to kind of dip
your toes in you got a it's gonna be
hard at first you're gonna get better at
it it's gonna be easier over time you
know so it's not that reading research
necessarily gets easier it's that you
just build up a bigger skillset you
become more efficient and you have more
experience to lean on as you go oh um so
we actually didn't address one part of
that question she asked how we read
research articles hmm yeah and I feel
like we've both alluded to it already
but so my process is I pull up the paper
I'll first take a glance at the abstract
just to kind of get an idea of what went
on in the study and then I skip the
intro or I'll read like the last two
sentences of the intro because that's
generally where the research questions
and hypotheses are and you would be
shocked the number of papers that don't
actually have hypotheses that relate at
all to the statistical test performed in
the study so I'll generally catch like
the last two two sentences or so of the
intro just to see like did they do what
they said they were gonna do and you
know then I'll read the methods section
like I said I'll either not spend a lot
of time on it or spend a lot of time on
it depending how well acquainted with
the methods they used how acquainted I
am with the methods they used if they're
if they're doing stuff that I don't
understand well I'll spend quite a bit
of time reading research um on the
methods they use to see what's going on
if I do understand what they did and I
read through it I'm like okay I could
explain in detail their methodology then
I move on to the findings read the
results section see like well first off
like did they use the appropriate
statistical test for their hypotheses
and research questions sometimes they
did
sometimes they done it did they report
the results appropriately and clearly
this is this is another whole big thing
that is maybe beyond what you
should be concerned about at this point
but you know if you're aware of how data
in a particular research niche tends to
look you might want to just look at the
structure of the data in various data
patterns to see if the findings are
harder plausible or if maybe there was
like some weird [ __ ] that went down but
for the time being if you're just
getting your feet wet you should
probably just assume that it's okay I
guess
and so then like that is the that is the
heart of the paper the the methods and
findings like that's what they did and
the rest is framing so then after that
I'll I'll read the intro to see
basically like you know how what what do
they think the important questions in
this field are and then how did their
their actual study relate to that stuff
and then I'll read the discussion
section see how it fits in with the rest
of the literature if I know the studies
they're referencing that they're
comparing and contrasting with sometimes
I'll pull them back up just to give them
a brief skim to make sure I remember
what happened in those papers often
times I'm like okay yep they're they're
using this paper correctly or no they're
using this paper incorrectly if it's an
area of research I'm not acquainted with
I'm at that point spending a shitload of
time pulling up studies referenced in
the discussion section to you know get a
better feel of that whole body of
research to see where where that one
study fits in and then like yeah that's
and then I'll compare and contrast what
I thought the paper was saying based on
the methods and results versus how the
authors interpreted their own findings
and some often times those match up
sometimes they don't if they don't then
it's worth rereading the methods and
results to see like did I misunderstand
something or are the authors
misinterpreting what they found
and yeah that's that's my basic process
yeah my process is pretty similar I
think though I don't know if it's a
difference but it's just so I definitely
go get an idea of what the studies about
you know see if we got a purpose
statement or hypotheses get into the
methods get in the results after that I
kind of skip I either look at like the
very first few sentences of the
discussion or the very end if there's
like a conclusion such section just to
kind of double-check like what I got
from the results is that what they got
from the results and it's that is that
how they framed it in their discussion
but honestly I usually if I don't know
the literature if it's a body of
literature that I have no experience
with like a study topic that I'm not
familiar with
I'll read the intro sometimes first just
to like get caught up to speed and then
read additional papers if I need to but
if it's a body of literature I feel
pretty good about I usually don't read
the introduction at all you know I've
said this before on the on the podcast
the first sentence of any introduction
could be cut and nothing would be lost
yeah but I wish the introduction
sections were just three bullet points
yeah I I think that would be fine but my
favorite is like every resistance
training study starts with resistance
training is commonly used to improve
athletic performance and increase muscle
mass it's just and they have like two or
three citations for and it's like we
don't need that well were you aware that
caffeine is one of the most widely used
psychoactive substances in the world try
that that's the challenge over our
summer break try to find me a caffeine
study that doesn't have that in the
introduction it'll be harder than you
think yeah like that is a good point mo
if you've read one introduction in like
a specific enough neesh of the
literature you've read all of them like
they become incredibly redundant after a
while yeah so I typically unless I have
no idea what's going on in this study I
typically don't read the introduction
really at any point the only exception
is
if if I'm reviewing it for a journal and
giving it a stamp of approval I need to
make sure it's not saying a bunch of
like just incorrect stuff in there right
but like for a for a mass review I'm not
going to be dwelling on whether or not
their introduction was accurate I want
to talk about the methods the results
and how they framed it in the
conclusions and yeah I'll take a very
close look at the discussion especially
if there's a mismatch between my
interpretation of the data and their
conclusions that's when I start to
really look at the discussion and say
well we're looking at the same data but
we have very different interpretations
so how did you arrive at yours and
whenever I do that I'm very open to the
possibility that I'm just wrong but but
you know aside from those I really think
most of the time ought to be focused on
methods results and then kind of
contextualizing them when it for
whatever you're doing writing it up for
a school assignment for research review
blog post whatever the case may be all
right anything to add I think that about
does it
alright so that does it for the current
season on the stronger by science
podcast we are gonna take our summer
break over the next few weeks we will
kind of drop some bonus audio content
here or there so make sure you keep an
eye out for that stay in touch with us
if you're feeling very sad about missing
out on our content for the next couple
months you can get on our email list we
do send out emails with research reviews
and stuff like that so you can stay in
touch with us there you can also stay in
touch with us on a variety of different
social media platforms as well or drop
by the site we'll have some written
content coming out as well so thanks for
listening we'll be back soon
take care and enjoy your summer thanks
for listening to the stronger by science
podcast now Greg and I are not experts
in medicine or health or really anything
else for that matter so before you make
any changes to your diet and exercise
habits make sure you check with a doctor
or another health care professional
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to support it visit stronger by
science comm to check out the products
and services that we offer thanks for
listening and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you